you
an absurdist Ryan are valid old wallet
mineral Edna Jamar Holloman morale hey
you control a dashed of warrenton fans
then
muhammad look be of wellington and put
semi afonso to say i am in ml in the
Sahaba to Iquitos laguna he we date
without the grand coalition of two con
agua de baja conceive sama yaseen
invalid Godfather attentive our fantasy
santillan fear not death Alinta father
will it's tacky addy
neff silly o Canada stash from Ellen
Show had also be asked the food doesn't
deserve for the camera for Donald from
her be radical a year delfino hamsa will
it happen arava gibberish
hey Emma cuanto seria lahoti relating to
Barry
install an air cannon
our odds are i accept Assad I shall
music oh so comfy
stop that immediately dish data about
others again become system Dormammu
analysis is my most often in 2 epsilon D
latina magna been installed on a career
jetta blame
rammohan sabarod fur neckwarmer hey
Kenisha Lola did find your name at
melange a speed bullet novel series
vakharia an appalled by his cinema soul
tel Aviv a kshama Kabuto a Tonka Bell
Telephone Roman her she was a hottie fat
autobus a nickel also her native hyphen
k the holy chiz radife at notables tavo
batty
that's a ratty been busy maximal who
Allah Allah mr. Magoo's name is named
can avail swoosh lemme I was Ella Dottie
very kuta mikata reza touch name of the
schemata kahuta bouta lay it would she
was insane there's a mature women
William came out my team if she really
mama came at me team was modest remote
McCarville a zulu shaka how was I to TL
gizelle oh darling l'shana freezing
powerful the team looks stomach away
they were bathing shove harlem toch
however my new blog amitava cara mi de
baisemeaux javamail why would see blooms
as a catcher had the live nation
completa mccord karate white apparel am
the leaf desert 0 Maha Shiva notable on
yahoo caca a canijo under there when
militia a new character from Kuala Brian
cheval am thoughts about whatever Lynch
italo a total physic no I Hilton
another new Arab namaha bill Xie dark
short you follow my emmalin basis hood
will be sure did honk lowly shall
attention him RF know how young suction
cup kuda beautiful kid bali my friends
david evans Nicholas Kiser George
Marshall and my beloved brother Dennis J
Tim child perry ellis Freddie Mercury
Peter Allen to the thousands of other
people who were made to suffer in
silence
I think the quilt itself does good stuff
and it's moving still it's like making
something beautiful out of the epidemic
and I felt like doing something like
this as a way of showing there's nothing
beautiful about it you know this is when
i'm left with i've got a box full of
ashes and bone chips you know there's no
beauty in that and i felt like a
statement like this is like saying this
is what george bush is done you know
this is a him in ronald reagan form of
done these are our loved ones and this
is what they've been reduced to and
we're bringing them to the person who's
responsible for their death
leave it that
you
one of the duties that Marine Barracks
Washington was a ceremonial drill the
evening parades are what you would see
on the news the silent drill platoon
president everybody goes to those type
of things Oh after the parades all the
officers are required to stay till
midnight and drinkin center house at
Marine Barracks Washington so we're
talking about wednesday night happy
hours that start at three and end up to
a it it was a partying and drinking
culture that mr. revolved around going
out and partying and drinking I was
ordered to drink I was ordered to attend
the drinking event my boss even said um
that they were mandatory to me she's
like we do her best work add these
events we went to various pubs and bars
and the goal was to do a shot at each
one all paid for by the Marine Corps
you're talking about during an events
were other senior officers are drinking
to the point of peeing in their pants
you know passing out on ma lawns this is
the norm at one bar I had water and I
was ordered to shot anyways and told I
needed to take two shots to make up for
that I left the bar to get a cab my
company commander followed me and said I
need to talk to you about some things so
we walked up the stairs into his office
there was a little bit of a struggle he
tried to kind of make in advance and
tried to kiss me I tried to leave and he
slammed the door on my arms I fell on
the ground and hit my face on his desk
and the next thing I realized was I had
woken up wearing his shorts with all of
my clothes off and in tremendous pain I
knew enough about me that something
wasn't right and I had felt entirely
violated
the colonel at one point said you know
lieutenant Helmer boys girls and alcohol
just don't mix we'll never really know
what happened inside that office only
you in the major no and he's not talking
so at this point the investigation is
closed for lack of evidence and we've
reopened a new investigation against you
for conduct unbecoming an officer and
public intoxication I remembered we're
going to the bar was an officer that
Sarah buying shots for us after I'd had
a couple drinks that's all I remember
this officer bragged to his fellow
officer friends that he had bagged me I
got called up to a majors office and he
charged me with fractions nation and
adultery he was married I wasn't and I
was charged with adultery I told
battalion XO about the humiliation in
the comments and he said you know you
should do what a Marine officer should
do and that's to ignore it and move on I
used to lie awake in bed you know
wondering what I could do to help her
get out he said that if I told anybody
he was gonna have his friend Marv from
Indiana kill me and throw me in a ditch
because that's how they took care of
things in Indiana she went to warp and
gave nine years for life for them to
take it and come back and say
yes they called you a [ __ ] yes they
called you a [ __ ] yes they called you a
walking mattress it's documented over
and over and over again but you deserved
it and you and when you complained about
it you were welcoming it the actions of
my seniors both in the assault and in
the ensuing investigations have really
destroyed me when when your wife doesn't
come home to remember rummage through
the house searching for the suicide note
to call the police with one hand well
you're straining her from killing
herself with the other
one
it was almost as if he didn't even have
to play they were just happy to see him
so for for a time I think they they
wanted to meet it was the Union it
wasn't it was something completely
different it was for everybody there i'm
sure the most exciting answer that ever
be too because it was unique we've never
seen rodriguez and then all you heard
was the bass player just playing
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do dignity
and audrey has wandered after the final
stage and the bass player extra to stop
playing and it took a while there was
about five or ten minutes of just people
screaming
you
thankfully
I
what'll I do
think to go from being the outcast to be
what he really was because it was as
though it was him okay and that was who
he was a musician at stage playing for
his fans it didn't God for Donovan
I thought that I would see you know him
being bobbled it at all these people
staring up at him that's what the
opposite i saw this absolute tranquility
there was absolute serenity on his face
total he just it's like it arrived at
that thing that place he try to find his
whole life home is acceptance as a guy
who lived somewhere else on the other
side of the earth and it was almost as
if he had found his home I looked around
at me all these people and I thought
this is a once-in-a-lifetime experience
this is never going to happen again
alright we've uh got three Israelis a
Palestinian a Swede a French woman hey
is the American oscars at a Brit where's
Simon are you are down there this I've
never seen so many foreign filmmakers as
nominated as we have this year this is
very so rapture a wonderful development
and because those of us who do see
documentaries from other countries were
just amazed at what's going on with non
fiction film in other parts of the world
so welcome to America thank you the
Jesus rough even just watching those
clips you know I just it you know what's
so powerful about all of your films
especially the first four and we'll get
to sugar man in a minute but what's
really powerful about these films and
what you did differently was instead of
just focusing on the the single story of
somebody who was wronged or the bad
apple in some organization when they
actually the organization is pretty good
it's just a couple bad apples here and
there you went right to the heart of the
institution your film goes right at the
Israeli government and the military and
what they do to civilians in a way that
we've never seen this footage in the
United States before the gatekeepers to
hear from the heads of the secret police
and to have them got to say the things
that they said and to go right at that
institution these are brave brave movie
so the two of you from Israel and
Palestine I mean it's just really it was
just incredible to watch and and then um
watching the ash is thrown over the
White House fence again I I could watch
that 20 times and I don't want to watch
it 20 times because I can't stop
crying watching that it's just in it but
again this wasn't the typical AIDS film
this again went right at the core and
said these people were murdering us and
we're going to show you how we stopped
it and it was it's just a powerful
powerful I encourage actually young
people to watch this film not so much
because of the AIDS part of this but
it's such a primer in how to organize a
movement when it looks like you have
absolutely no chance of winning it's
just very powerful um our army the
recruitment film that the two of you
made ah who have you seen how many have
seen the Invisible War man and I said
you last night kirby again yeah the
typical film like that would have you
know pointed you know gone after the two
or three in the unit and you're saying
no it's it's not that and it's the fact
that there are 17,000 sexual assaults
19,000 each year there's something wrong
institutionally not with just a bad
apple or two and then um and Malik and
Simon uh I have a special place in my
heart for your film searching for
sugarman because it's about two fellow
michigander and and I gotta tell you man
those of us in Michigan people have seen
the film it's a huge hit in detroit and
flint and elsewhere because everybody
feels a piece of that of themselves
neglected overlooked ignored having to a
really work to make ends meet even in
spite of the fact he may have this
incredible talent and the fact that he
went unknown for all those years and had
to be discovered by south africans and
became an icon in their movement against
apartheid an unknown person fixing roofs
in detroit
yes it was just I just had no idea when
I first saw the film what it was about I
thought he was actually dead for the
first half of the film until it was
revealed and and the way you shot
Detroit I told you this before I've
never I've never seen a film that has
shown Detroit in the way that you showed
it and I think it took you from Sweden
uh to be able to I can't I never I've
never shot dieter like that I don't know
anybody else who shot dieter like that
because we don't we see it differently
you see it that the way you saw through
your eyes and it just again I was in
tears three minutes into the film it was
just as such a powerful powerful movie
that's all i've got to say thank you and
good night oh is this i just wish we
have a tie rule and it's just it's it's
I know it's gonna it's gonna feel like a
crime that four of you are going to get
the Oscar on Sunday but please know that
for you just heard from the audience
here in you you'll have you already
heard this around the country in the
world you'll continue to hear it that
you've done something very important and
it will inspire younger other
documentary filmmakers to make films
like this you have no idea how 2012 is
going to be one of those watershed years
and non fiction cinema in terms of what
you are going to have inspired in so
many other filmmakers so thank you very
much for that
so I got a text last night we were at
that we were at this dinner the Beverly
Hills to honor everyone here and we're
standing there we're drinking a little
cocktail thing beforehand and you know
we're waiting there's somebody missing
mod hasn't shown up yet well okay you
know we'll just drink some more and so
he just we're kind of waiting around and
all of a sudden my blackberry goes off
yes I'm selling the blackberry and it's
ahmad from a holding pen at LAX they
have detained him and his wife and his
son because he told them he was here
because he was an oscar nominee and they
just they couldn't wrap their head
around the fact that a Palestinian olive
farmer was also an Oscar nominee and
they basically threatened to send you
back last night let's just address this
very briefly so we can get on to the
movies just because I know a lot of
people have asked me about it on the way
in here just maybe give us the 90 second
version of what happened to you last
night and again our apologies that you
had to go through this and possibly not
be here tonight yeah for me to go
through this and to just the desktop
need for questions security questions
and to give them more documents and more
approve about why I came here to United
States I this moment remind me of where
I live and where I come from because I
live this situation I live under
occupation I live under Israeli control
and I go through many checkpoints
through many borders to get out from the
country to Jordan to take the flight so
for me it's became like a normal life
and the you know I they hold us for
since we get to the airport in los
angeles we it's all the process about
one hour and a half me and my son and my
life and my son asked me why why they
hold us what what we have done why so I
told him the they might send us back so
we were very tired and he was very tired
and he was very angry and upset because
he want to attain the Oscar and he want
to do yeah and he wants to to get sleep
because he was very tired so he told me
I cannot go another flight 15 hours back
so yeah so it was you know say I feel
that they will send us back because the
officer lady she told me if you if you
don't come up with the documents there
with the approve why came here to united
states so we will send you back to your
country so it's it's very easy to google
my name and Toto to search and to get
the the information but I don't know
what happens to it to them Homeland
Security doesn't have google yet I think
that's the answer well it's a we got
right on it Don Hudson and Hawk our
president to the Academy and called our
lawyers and I made some coffee everybody
hopped right on it ahmad and i think
within a half hour so it things moved
very fast and and we got you here and
we're very happy that you're here so our
apologies again how'd you get here guy
how are you it's been very painful i
have to say this process of releasing
this film and especially from the moment
that we were nominated for the oscar i
don't know i think when you imagine that
you're going to be nominated to the
oscar it's going to be a moment of joy
and it's going to be very you know just
a lot of happiness and satisfaction and
maybe maybe it's also me because i see
in every point of happiness i see
sadness in every point of sadness i find
happiness i think also he can feel it in
the film for me it's the same as
when jabrill is born and the olive trees
are cut I find myself there because I
see a moment of joy and then I see
destruction and they are all tied up and
when he might is treated in the hospital
and at the same time when he is awake
and he gets his life back from Israeli
doctors but at the same time the war in
Gaza starts and one more than 1,500
people are massacred so there is healing
and there's destruction and are always
tied together so maybe because of that
at the moment that the nomination of the
Oscar I was declared for me immediately
there were so many challenges that I
started to think well maybe we should
not have been nominated because a whole
discussion about the nationality of the
film started a lot of territorialism and
talks about the identity of the film
which is not what the film is about it's
not the subject of the film is not
dealing with the occupation is not
dealing with what the responsibilities
that israeli society has towards
palestinian with the occupation so we
shifted the whole discussion about to
the political world into the political
own language in which the identity of
the film became the center of it and I
think that was and I'm and we're still I
think we're in a very vulnerable moment
both of us because we are under a lot of
different kind of pressures because we
are at aunt you been attacked by people
no no I wasn't attack an attack
physically but you know threatening
letters are part of our lives so that's
not it's not I think it's somewhere more
about we see an opportunity with this
phone that it can really create change
in the language and the way the film is
talking about reality it takes us it
uses another kind of language sometimes
maybe derives from the spiritual world
and sometimes they write some emotional
confrontation that we have in life and I
think this film has a possibility to
really to shift people that are the most
non convinced and the most far from this
from these ideas and that just speaking
about Palestinian occupation brings them
to chill and suddenly you see they
changing their opinions and then once
the film is released and and becomes a
part of the public the public owns it
then the whole discussion around the
film takes it back and and then
everything that was achieved is lost so
it's been very painful I'm sorry about
that we all go out drinking afterwards
that'll help with some great spots here
in LA cheery up I feel bad about this i
think that i saw the film last week at
the Jewish Community Center in Manhattan
and that was a very interesting audience
I came in with I think a lot of them
with one set of ideas and I know many of
them left with a different set of ideas
and you could have heard a pin drop
through most of this movie to watch
Israeli soldiers purposely shoot unarmed
civilians civilians that they have
handcuffed and a soldier just walks up
on your camera walks up and just shoots
this Palestinian civilian in the knee no
provocation nothing just shoots them you
see it your friend on camera we see this
man died shot by the Israelis this with
a tear gas canister shot in the head or
the chest and all this and I think what
makes this film so brave is that because
you're showing non-violence is the way
to do this the way to respond and that's
what scares them i think that's my own
personal opinion because non-violence
will work is a historical back up for
this and you know they they rue the day
that 10,000 or 100,000 Palestinians will
just sit down in the middle of the road
and not get up that is just very
powerful and I just I am glad you're
here I'm glad you're part of this and
and you've made an incredible movie and
I think it is going to get a lot of
people thinking and talking how has it
been receiving in the Palestinian
audiences I just want to talk about the
non-violence resistance it's not a new
way it's not the start it was not an
my village or and other village so if
you remember the first intifada its was
a popular resistance and the nonviolent
resistance but you know since 2000 with
the second default Intifada started so
you see a lot of violence and lot many
people getting killed and so the media
focus just on the violet and other
political issues and they never focus on
the nonviolent resistance of the of the
people so in my village the creative of
the the ideas of the nonviolent
resistance who makes the village like my
village became a symbol of the the
nonviolent resistance and everybody
knows about my village everybody talked
about the village and saw what's made I
think what's made the film is the
success of the film it's the the onyx
story and the the the long period of
shooting seven years of shooting the the
reality and the about the life not just
the actions or demonstrations it's about
life about how kids grow up there and
how how people live there it's very it's
through my personal respective through
my story I live there so I'm related to
to to the place there I'm everything
what's happened what's happening they're
related to me and affected me so how do
you think that you actually came to arm
too I mean the way this is filmed it's
just I mean you did not go to film
school you're a farmer by trade so um
you just picked up your first camera a
little little tiny I don't know what it
was a sony handycam or something was
just a little small thing and and you
just started filming yeah my face camera
was panasonic camera and i started
filming like anyone who just wanted him
but i want to film for different
purposes because the the village decided
to resist against the construction
against the wall against the Israeli
occupation so I wanted to do it to take
part of this
and I learned by myself on the ground
down to film and how how to eat it and
how to think about the the ideas how to
get the ideas of making films I think if
you if you want just to think about to
be a filmmakers and how to make a films
and you should have the the the the
message what's your message and what's
what's your goal by making this film if
you relate it to the place and related
to the subject by your feeling and you
you have the experience so I think you
will make a very powerful story and work
very powerful documentary so I was
related to the place and I I feel that
so it's not easy to feel how to live
under occupation how to live how to have
all these experience all my life 40
years I i I've been through this and to
start thinking about making a
documentary just for making a
documentary and making another
documentary without thinking about
what's your message or what's your goal
what you want to achieve of making
documentaries documentary is about
reality and about truth so my goal
always been to show to reach the bball
and to show the film to the bball so so
we can make change on our life and i
make i can make change to my kid gibril
and talk to his generation so can live
in peace and then freedom and then
different experience are you give us on
American TV do know is that has anybody
bought this film yet because I honestly
I have this amir maybe I'm just a weird
optimist but I think if every American
or as many as possible would watch this
movie there would be a see
shift a sea change unlike anything that
we've seen because I know most people
ever have a good heart and a conscience
if they watched this for a hundred
minutes boy that's makes this a very
dangerous movie and I don't know how
you're going to get it on American TV
but if I was good the film is going to
be broadcast in POV later and I'm peel
be on PBS okay wow great so if we can
get him to watch Downton Abbey on PBS we
can get him to watching this right we
now know that people will watch PBS all
right and God bless you man as an
Israeli 44 sick of your neck out and
going there and doing this in helping
out you are truly a brother to all these
people and I think they're very grateful
that you've done Kirby and Amy this film
has already altered a policy we've
actually seen real maybe not necessarily
everything that needs to happen but it
was actual substantive change as a
result of this particular movie won't
tell the people the story this well sure
several months after the film premiered
at sundance leon panetta saw in the film
and two days later held a press
conference where he announced some very
important first steps you're absolutely
right there's they've got to go a lot
further but we we later learned that the
reason he held the press conference
actually was in part because of the
impact the film made on him and then
it's you know it's just it's actually
just continued it's actually become the
reference point for the issue in
Congress in the military and in the
administration in fact to date well the
military started using it at part of its
sexual assault training program which is
something we never expected at all and
to date 250,000 men and women in the
military have seen the film
it was just I just felt really sick
watching it just and I you know I mean
I'm sure most people everybody says I
support the troops but I don't know
what's really to say after that because
something something was seriously wrong
and the fish rots from the head down and
you know I I hope this continues I mean
it really and I'm surprised about
Panetta to that he I mean that's too
good as to figs I've I mean he was
played by Tony Soprano in zero dark
thirty at james gandolfini and he
actually just came down to the lunchroom
duh because he heard about this redhead
it had some ideas and now he's two days
after seeing your movie so I don't know
there's something there may be a PBS
will do something with it but anyways
thank you for making the movie a David
and Howard um where how did you wrap
your head around this and not David
you're you're an editor at or sub so she
ate earlier they were contributing at
are contributing interview New York
Magazine York magazine now have you made
a documentary of film this is your first
documentary Wow yes
and and so you obviously made a decision
early on that this wasn't going to be
that we've seen the AIDS documentary
over and over and over again but this
was something different and this was
something that I'm just curious what
your what your process was with that
because you obviously made a decision
not to make the the standard and I'm not
knocking those films I mean they're
wonderful great films I'm glad we have
them but but you went for something
different well the reason I decided to
take on this project was because the
because of those many aids documentaries
all brilliant all-powerful important
films they the AIDS plays the AIDS
non-fiction books memoirs all of those
stories captured about half of what
happened in the play gears in America
before 96 when the drugs came out and
made survival possible and they all
stopped before the anybody could even
imagine the end of that of that period
and what they missed was activism what
they missed was the the community the
gay community principally in their
allies and the community of scientists
and doctors who were actually doing
heroic work and trying to find a way
through the epidemic to the other side
and I you know I've often said that that
I think that the body of work the canon
of AIDS work that existed before how to
survive a plague was about what HIV did
to a community and the rest of the story
is what the community did to HIV and
nobody for some reason had told it all
these years later and and you can't
really understand AIDS without knowing
what what this amazing grassroots mass
movement did to bring survival into the
realm of possibility well thank you very
much for
for showing how that happened resistor I
gave David the best documentary worth
the National Board of Review and I'm
sorry the new york film critics and so
they asked me to hand him the award and
i was just talking a little bit about
the film and i remember first moving to
new york and act up going in
interrupting Mass at st. Patrick's
Cathedral and and being a recovering
catholic i found that to be entertaining
and some catholic in the audience just
started screaming at me on the stage
before i gave you the awards i guess
there's still some sensitivities about
about act up and but thank God as crazy
as they were you need the crazies to get
out there and and kick things off I
guess movements don't start with with
you know people who are sitting at home
in their loafers there there was no you
couldn't do that I mean or you would die
and that's what that's what this period
of time was about in New York and
elsewhere and still in most of the world
that doesn't have access to the drugs
but the reason I became a documentarian
to tell this story was because of the
existence of this incredible body of
footage that was shot as you as you were
describing by people who were involved
in this struggle in real time as things
were unfolding including inside the
church and well you saw from the from
the clip if you haven't seen the film
that it's that it's built on this
archival vintage footage you know I had
not seen that the demonstration throwing
the ashes I mean I know where I was but
I'm you know you don't think I'm the
only one didn't see that you you show so
many things that the nightly news just
didn't exactly mean that's why that's
why it was so important that people were
they were their own cameras and if you
look in those panning shots and in all
those the wide shots and all those
amazing seminal demonstrations you don't
see a news camera you don't see the
night nightly news there it was being
ignored in an almost energetic way to
make sure that this story of empowerment
of response of agency was was a went
unacknowledged in
and this movement this time really had
has become the first movement that
recorded its own history in in video in
motion pictures it's being done now when
we see it you know all the way up
through the Arab Spring we see in your
film here we see it as a kind of a
commonplace and an empowering way to
document what the larger culture is
paying no attention to but what we
discovered in the and the research for
how to survive a plague was the very
first use of this this powerful tool the
the video camera to to create a witness
account and and leave it so that
somebody like me years later can come
and and purpose it in in this kind of
larger epic way using you know we
brought together Howard and I did 33
different sources of this footage it was
shot by artists and activists and people
who had sometimes no skill with a camera
sometimes family members and and when it
went to gether you can you can really
see a history unfold that no one else
was privileged to see right and I just
want to acknowledge the the chair of our
branch Rob Epstein who kicked off the
evening tonight made real i think one of
the first films adult with gay issues
america he made the Harvey Milk
documentary back in the late 70s and so
there's a nice through line from Rob to
you sitting up here on on his shoulders
yeah yeah my friends from Sweden in
Britain none of us in Detroit Michigan
had ever heard of Rodriguez didn't have
any idea who he was we think we're
pretty hip and we're pretty on top of
the music scene there from Motown to
Iggy Pop to the white stripes to Madonna
Bob Seger and our our favorite Ted
Nugent
that but it is it is slightly
embarrassing but we're very grateful
that it took people from thousands of
miles away who did not grow up in our
culture did not really were not familiar
with Michigan to make this incredible
film and i'm just i'm curious if Malik
was this is this your first theatrical
documentary is this yes it is your while
but apparently the regus wrote a letter
to you ten years ago asking if you
wanted to make his doc it's a true story
I get too much mail I know he'd say I
walked out of the first screening of
this and I'd never met him and he came
up to me he said you could have made
this film I sent you a letter 10 years
ago so open your mail know if you know
this Simon has also won an Oscar he
produced man on wire um he he produced a
project nim which is the Jameses next
film and so many other wonderful films
that you've been behind over the years I
mean you're a good guy to know and and
you're there for documentary filmmakers
and and he'll be at a table out back for
any of you who need funding for your
next movie but Malik tell us about tell
us the story of this what drew me to
destroy but I assure you if you would
have read that letter you would have
done it because it was the best it was
the best way I ever heard I mean it was
just it sounded like it was scripted you
know fiction work of fiction so it was
pretty when I fun destroy it was pretty
easy to see it it could work so that's
it it was a great story yeah yes let's
do it that's it yeah yeah it was yeah so
it didn't take you very long before
between the time you thought about doing
it and let's just then let's get started
and we did take that because i only did
like six minutes stories with swedish
television before so for me to start
thinking that something longer was
possible to go out but you get that did
you get swedish television to put up the
money for this or initially some young
and then it was many years so nothing oh
what a lot of begging and
yeah yeah yeah you know how it is
because they couldn't see the genius of
the story no well then if it was 90%
finished the main Thunder which was the
serum institute said that different was
not good enough for the feature-length
format or the big screen that needed to
be re-edited into for one hour TB doc
and I saw God I got a tight that's not
only a province sweet and everybody at
this stage has heard this are you have
this incredible feature length film and
and has to be 53 minutes and it's like
oh my god 53 minutes searching for
sugarman would just be it would suck
they would that's PP well I'm glad I'm
glad you persevered because boy that
this film has entertained audiences all
over this country and it's a it's a it's
really just a very powerful film in a
wonderful story and and thank you for
coming to our shores to tell it to
really appreciate it
we began with Israel Palestine will come
to our final nominated film by drawer I
said that right drawer which you
actually told me earlier it's Hebrew for
sterile um sparrow and Frida's barrel
sparrow oh that's your mind speaking mr.
paging dr. Freud he's not answering you
he gave up that with you a long time ago
that's why I'm not gonna open any more
mail good I this will be my last
appearance on any stage sparrow and
freedom both of them I see ok so how
popular are you in Israel right now mr.
sparrow the Prime Minister loves me the
Prime Minister loves you I love probably
not right what's been the reaction they
must be shocked that people that they
consider of their cloth um were so
willing to be so honest on camera to you
this must have really stirred the pot
recently in Israel and I'm just curious
first of all how you got these six what
drug you used you put in their coffee or
whatever to get them to say these things
well it's the question that I've been
asked at la I think six thousand times
in the last month how did I get them to
speak well you don't get those people to
speak if they don't want to speak and I
think that they the timing to ask them
to speak was very good for them I think
they wanted to convey a very strong
message and I think in a way it served
what they wanted to say at the end of
the day basically we
served our country in the center of the
defense establishment and we were the
one that were responsible to maintaining
let's say the security of Israel and now
when we are standing looking back we are
saying in a very loud and clear voice
enough of occupation it's not heading
it's not good for Israel first and
foremost and that the best thing that
can happen is that Israel will move as
fast as it can genuinely and honestly
towards trying to reconciliation with
the Palestinians the arm it really had a
sense I had a sense at least watching it
these were men who were now aged or old
and getting near the end of their lives
in some cases some of them some of them
yes not all of them not all of them but
i but but the ones who were older I
really they just had that look or that
sense of wanting to come clean wanting
to speak truth from their conscience in
a way that I never would have expected
to see on film I mean I just I was
really I was really moved by it and
again gave me some hope that even people
who who were the heads of and
participated in some dastardly awful
things that they did to Palestinians
that they would that their conscience is
you know not completely buried that it's
still there and operating yeah I think
look if I if there is something that is
common to all of them is the fact that
they I think that they are very
pragmatist in a way and I think that
they understand that use it using force
in order to suppress and other people
whatever the reason to suppress them is
and I'm not going into the reasons for
that but they understand that it can
never end in a good way unless you reach
a political solution
and a political solution is really
something that only politicians can
create on both sides it's not that the
Israelis can do that alone they have its
two to tango and I think when they look
back at what they did and all those
things that you mentioned and they look
at the future in a way they understand
that nothing could good can come up with
maintaining that and this is I think the
most important reason for me to create
that film was that the message come from
this this kind of people I mean a lot of
movies have been done on the
israeli-palestinian conflict from a lot
of amazing directors and they all kind
of set over and over the same thing
authors writers but the fact that for
the first time all the living six head
of the Israeli Secret Service are coming
and saying and conveying this message is
something that I feel no one can ignore
you know it's all of them there is no
one who said i will i'm not willing to
participate in this film there is no one
who is left out all of them are coming
and saying the same message at the end
it should stop it's tell now Stella and
Philippe hora de you are the two
producers of this film and one of you is
Israeli and one is from France I'm just
curious where how you came in to be part
to be part of this and you know just
give us a little understanding of what
it was like while making this woman
what's happened to you in terms of
reaction in israel since then i will
toss you hear you tell about the
reaction in israel because she knows
more than I do Philip I came to me three
years ago I think was a four okay long
time ago with a project and they were
Israeli partner on boards the user a
channel was was already partner from the
start and the on the FEMEN they had been
pitching the famine in Switzerland and
I had a lot of interest from European
TVs there and she feedback came to me
and say thank you you could you know get
involved in the added stage and help us
some found the film here and we received
promoters support from different
european countries and strong supporter
from france for this policy and i think
it's it's a film that people really
wanted to see and really expect it and
so that we really were strongly and
quite quickly supported it didn't it
that didn't take long but i have to say
that its tail's position in the film was
not only as a fundraiser so not only
someone who brought in financing she was
a real co-producer super active and
every frame you see in the film it's
true so it was important also for this
film to 24 I think both full of photo
and Philippa to also have a kind of
hours in international I in to have you
know there's something else oh it's so
close to them and the other thing that
we don't know was a foreigner and I
think the discussion altar in the
editing room just just helped to bring
the film also to the international
international audience which was really
important for this because if there was
something that it still wasn't sure
about it was obvious that no one else
would know so we'd have to re-edit it to
make it comprehend I have to I have to
add to that that this was the first
movie that I did that I understand why
you need producers all the movies that i
did before that i didn't understand why
you need the producers it's basically
there was there but but with them it was
really if I could say in the very deep
sense of the word collaboration on all
aspect of the movie and most most
important for me was creatively
creatively in terms of content in terms
of shaping the amount of debates we had
about the animation could fill I don't
know what books how why do you want to
do that and by doing that it helped me a
lot to reach a much better solution as a
director and as a producer I get the
sense of talking last night that the
other producers up here
on the stage and the directors feel the
same way with Howard with how to survive
a plague and Amy with the Invisible War
and Simon of course do any of you want
to weigh in on this or if you're too
modest maybe your directors can talk
about the collaborative process with the
producer who oftentimes and maybe other
kinds of filmmaking as can be a volatile
situation well yeah I mean I mean
filmmaking is completely collaborative
obviously but I one of the things I
think it's interesting about documentary
is oftentimes when the producing is
actually directing oftentimes it's like
oftentimes setting up a relationship
with a subject is in many ways the most
important thing that's done in the
directing stage is to get a a subject
feeling very close to the project
willing to open up and you know and
oftentimes the directing is producing
there's so much going back and forth
that that's certainly in our film that
was extremely important I mean Amy did
all the interviews with all the
survivors and in you know in part
because you know mostly we were talking
with women and it would seem very
appropriate for a woman to be talking
about another woman's rape experience
but it was also because Amy had set up
such close relationships with all these
subjects that it didn't it didn't seem
right to hand it off I mean she was
ready to go and really ask the questions
and set up the safe space where they
were able to talk there is a very smart
guy I mean and a very very smart guy
which is great I mean I suppose this is
a kind of unusual project for me I mean
man on why was the project that I sort
of come across and originated and
brought James to it and it's a very very
long journey to both of us this film was
very much Malick's baby I guess to some
extent I mean I get involved he was on
the this long marathon really on his own
very solitary and at a certain point I
think he just got a little desperate
everyone was turning him down creatively
I guess you know you were
being a bit of a funk and I had the very
good fortune that he came to me because
he thought I might have a sort of
similar sensibility but I very much sort
of played I guess the role as well as
helping raise some money of sort of
midwife you know maybe a kind of midwife
performing you know difficult you know
giving a difficult birth maybe with
forceps or an emergency c-section I
don't quite know what the analogy is but
you know and we worked you were very I
suppose you were very much looking for a
sort of creative collaborator at that
point and so we had this kind of very
very intense sort of creative dialogue
and it was great fun and I think you
know but uses a credit yeah sending some
clip0 run it's yeah it was very
pleasurable thank you if there is
something you know in the last four
months since the gatekeepers premiered
in Telluride Film Festival if there is
something that I learned which I didn't
know before i came to america is how
important the distributor are in terms
of when you finish the film and you have
a product and someone comes and believes
in that and gets it into completely
another universe and if there is
something that i am very thankful and
grateful for is the sony picture classic
people michael barker and tom bernard
who took this film and basically
rocketed it I mean this is something
that you don't really know when you are
doing that you want to finish your movie
in to do it as good as it can but then
when it's finished and it is out there
you need someone to take it and when I
see and I learned so much this month
when you see how much work and effort
and thinking went in to take that and to
move it where it is now where we are
sitting here in this audience with this
wonderful golden statue
near us so it's really an amazing listen
to me and I think them really from the
bottom can i also just yes they also
they also distribute searching for sure
because I think Michaels in the room but
I mean where you're at the beginning of
that particular Road and we're at the
end of it and Sony classics have done an
extraordinary job for our film as well
and you know wasn't always that certain
to us that it was going to be what it
ended up being in terms of the release I
mean it didn't open in a way that made
me feel you know but it was a kind of
slam dunk in any way but those guys
absolutely backed it and assured us from
day one that we should just be patient
and you know we listened not saying we
were particularly patient but we did
listen and and they were right they were
absolutely right and it takes a really
great distributor to do that and they
are that well let me let me uh let me
just throw a couple things out here and
then and then I want to just before we
wrap this up tonight I want to talk
about the future of documentary film and
what you know like you say you've
learned this particular thing and I
think everybody in the stage has
probably learned something through the
experience of these particular films and
I think be nice if you shared that with
with the audience before we we do that I
just want to say quit the dinner last
night a debate began here between a mod
and and the drawer there mr. sparrow and
and it was it was pretty intense and it
I think you you you despair the rest of
us from the road them from it you switch
to Arabic and Hebrew so we couldn't
quite hear their the rest of that debate
but I'm just curious what how did that
end and and and what I mean it's very
it's odd that two of the five nominated
films this year deal with the Israeli
occupation of Palestine that that has
never happened before in the the Academy
and it happened this year and I don't
think it's a fluke and I'm just I'm I
think this is on people's minds and I'm
and I think a lot of people have been
asking you okay well now what do we do
what do we do and you started in on that
last night and and I'm glad you switched
to Arabic and Hebrew because i was
getting less hopeful listen to you but
i'm just curious if you want to share
that any of that with the audience here
tonight you want to start mad and don't
be and you don't want you said to me
last night don't don't be afraid I mean
just really you're you're you're amongst
good-hearted people yeah you know it's
not the difficult to meet with the
Israeli and Palestinians and to sit
together to work together after to have
dinner or lunch together and but when
you start the discussion about when you
touch the subject and you start the
discussion about the the land and about
the occupation and about the situation
so you feel that you are you are not so
close to each other so you you stuck
there because they have different ideas
they have a different mentality how they
think about Palestinians and it's not
equal it's not equal because we live
under the occupation will event of the
Israeli occupation and they have the
power they have everything and we have
nothing so all of our our parts our life
if every part of our life is connected
to the occupation and related to the
occupation and we are affected by the
occupation so we start the discussion
and we we we had fun and we work
together but in the end so what's what's
what's the result of a meeting and the
gathering Israelis and Palestinians in
the end he goes to Tel Aviv and I stay
there in my own life under the brushes
under the armour control so i think it's
it's not the solution just to
collaborate and to meet and to sit
together it's good to talk and go to
meet but it's not the solution the
solution it should be come from
politician and the from from the people
who can make decisions about the
situations and to make the this happens
it should be from a like Israel it
should be from united states to put more
pressure on united in israel on the
government to make solution because as I
told him yesterday I don't have nothing
to give you I am seeking for peace and
the freedom i'm seeking for peace for my
kids and freedom for his generations I
don't want them to to have the same
experience that I go through all my life
so I told him that and so I don't have
nothing to give you it's very simple if
that between me and him you just we can
live two sides it's two states and you
give me my freedom my piece and you you
get what yet you just go out they leave
me alone so it's very it's very simple
so when we say that we have problems
with the both sides I don't think we are
problem with the both sides so if you
want to take the discussion to to the to
the political it achill language so
always you're stuck because if you say
we don't have partners on the other side
you do have but you are not serious so
the problem is how the people think and
how they could change the policy and the
strategy of the state and to think about
the other people because the other
people is also human and they want to
live and they want to survive as if
woman so myself I don't feel hit against
him he's Israeli and I live in Tel Aviv
but I don't feel that I hate him but
sometimes I felt that in the eyes of the
soldiers many soldiers I feel that hate
against me when I used to film them and
to use my camera I haven't done nothing
for them but I felt that's it they beat
me they shot me so I don't think wow
what is after a speech like that it's
hard to look yeah but we are living in
the reality we are not living in dream
level dreamland both of us by the way
look I can never imagine even start to
imagine how it is to live emad life I
think I know that to be a Palestinian
under occupation of my country is
probably horrible it is horrible for any
kind of human being to be under
suppressed another military occupation
where you are not free wherever everyone
can determine where you go when you go
and this is why i created my film for
who comes from the Israeli point of view
and trying to persuade to stop that I
think that there's a lot of fear if I
can speak from the Israeli side there's
a lot of fear there's a lot of mistrust
there's a lot of bad bad leaders
definitely and you can say you know that
the fact at the end of the day is that
there is one people who is under
occupation by another and we spoke about
it yesterday and one of the greatest
source of inspiration for me to create
that film was fog of war by
Morris and the first lesson of fog of
war by Robert McNamara is empathized
with your enemy and I think that this is
something that every leader should
acquire to think from the other side to
see how the other side see things and I
think definitely both sides have to do
that in order to reach a better better
future I am very bleak after creating
the film that I did I think that the
Israelis and the Palestinian both don't
have it within themselves to solve the
problem don't have the power and the
kind of leadership that needs to move
forward in order to solve that problem I
can state very clearly about the Israeli
current administration they don't have
anything which can contribute to that on
the contrary and I think I totally agree
with a mod unless the international
community headed by the u.s. headed by
the last four years of President Obama I
think there is now if you ask me and
this is my only personal point of view
there is a very very short window of
opportunity and if that window will not
be met by a lot of force from the
international community it will be shut
down very soon and nothing with this
will be as one of my chapter in my movie
victory for us is to see you suffer
basically both sides will can continue
to create suffering for the other side
much more inflicted because Israel is a
much stronger power definitely and again
unless the politicians which has to do
that this is their job and if there will
be no kind of really big force used by
the US and the US can do that definitely
if Obama will want he knows he have the
leverage is to do that towards Israel
definitely and also towards the other
side nothing will happen and it will
only get worse and worse
I'm sorry that I'm so bleak searching
for Sugarman is much you know we much
more oh yeah yeah happy ending
everybody's happy there so yeah but
except rodriguez still lives in Detroit
but at all but he's performing I heard
that he performed in South Africa's
however yeah and it's full concert so
we're trying to get him back here for
the Oscars on Sunday night so well um
well I'm not bleak I don't want to be
bleak I know in America you didn't leave
you well I live in the country that
writes the checks exactly so so I do
have a responsibility in this as is
everybody in this audience see this
nonsense end and no there the headline
the headline of the figure oh I still
told me Lamont sorry two weeks ago said
to mr. Obama before you go to Israel for
your visit in march watch the
gatekeepers and maybe it will change
something in you how the way you
understand the consequences of this
conflict I taught I believe if he
watched the gatekeepers and five broken
cameras ah this I this would be the
should have been here in the audience
today maybe well in fact he is ladies
and gentlemen believe me after last
night's experience with lax they're
paying attention to what's happening
this way care thanks to the federal
government's treatment of one of the
people on this stage I listen you made
these great films the more Americans
that see them including President Obama
the less bleak I think things can be so
thank you for making them and appreciate
that so
to wind up here that question I asked
you've had some time to think about it
the future of a documentary things have
really changed over the last decade or
two and it's led to this moment of these
very powerful and incredible films we
have up here and we just have a couple
of minutes left but if anybody would
like to this is your moment to say
something about what you would like to
see happen this is you're in a community
of many documentary filmmakers out here
academy members and people from the
public who love non fiction cinema where
do we go from here how do we use this
incredible art form to do good for the
world but also to produce great cinema
and to give people an exhilarating
experience for a couple of hours in a
movie theater and I think something that
we've definitely learned is now we have
the technological means to revisit the
past in order to reimagine the future
and you know I think this was one of
many stories about aids that could be
told but also that um move other
movements and hopefully people will see
a film like this and all the other films
as an opportunity to tell more of those
stories great I hope that's true yes
anybody else that's the thing that there
was a time when documentaries were
television oriented and I feel that
maybe thanks to the new technology and
maybe thanks to where documentaries in
general are I don't know but
documentaries have a wider and the wider
they get outside television they're
going to do really well in cinemas
non-theatrical educational maybe via
digital but they're going to have a
bigger and enrich your life and I think
that's really cool I mean we're still we
still need television often to fund the
films especially in Europe and pushing
myself into Europe now but when we get
funding we still using television but
afterwards we can cross the ocean and it
can become a big feature film and we can
use films different different places
than we could before the Americans how
do we get how do we get more of our
documentaries in the movie theaters
because television we do get a lot of
the money from
vision and then and does that does kind
of control but we're making cinematic
theatrically released documentaries just
curious what your thoughts are like
Kirby or well you know actually I in
that regard actually I think that this
is a golden age for documentary because
they're seen in many places including
theaters I mean you know I mean for
example netflix i mean you continually
have this dialogue with people who've
seen a film a year or two or three years
later so i think that's very encouraging
obviously theaters are sort of still the
catalyst to make all this happen but you
know i think i mean if you look at the
documentaries this year i mean you know
they're 25 30 that just that you know
that were just all phenomenal films they
all could have been nominated and we
probably only saw half of you know the
really great films even here you know
because there's probably so many
international films that we we didn't
see our weren't submitted so I mean it's
it bodes very well if it continues like
it you know what we saw this year
there's no question and there's
definitely still theatrical life I mean
ifc center in new york is like it makes
it mints money i think for Doc well I
for that theater too as well for the
documentaries and I think it's making
stories using the compelling methods
that a script of directors and
filmmakers use to apply to documentary
storytelling as well to bring people
into the issues through the stories and
characters like the films that we have
here tonight for many years documentary
filmmakers were concentrating on
covering stories so they were going as
adventurous to different places of
trying to find access to different
people that would their stories weren't
told and I think the more stories will
come from the communities themselves
like we see mother took a cameron and
that will be probably the next coming
years will will have a lot a lot of
footage and a lot of ways to deal with
that footage and that probably also will
create also a lot of chaos because we'll
be exposed to a lot of new issues told
by the communities and a lot of the old
filmmakers will be probably a little bit
out of job
so for me the real future of
documentaries would be when we start to
understand the documentaries in order to
do documentaries we have to use a lot
more of imagination and I think people
seem to think that in documentaries
there is no imagination that you just
approach to the reality and just pick
some important details and then you
edited and that's it but I think in that
good filmmakers understand that in that
process of it there's a lot of
imagination that is involved not just in
the editing sometimes during actually
the film one when you're trying to
figure out what kind of scene what kind
of emotions and I think the more for me
this is the future of documentary
filmmaking is to dare to find to kind of
summon new realities and new ways of
obtaining the stories well I've thank
you for saying that at it's been a real
honor for me to get to know all of you
it's a great group I hope you continue
to make these films is everybody got
their speech written for Sunday night no
yeah okay trust me at 45 seconds they
will the microphone will start to go
down into the stage and the band will
start playing but well good luck to all
of you I know we're rooting for all of
you and thank all of you for being here
tonight at this wonderful event let's
hear for them one more time